[Music]
hello there
fortnight season six is coming to a
close and today
saw the final update before the brand
new season
the island is now full of secrets to
uncover which should shape the story
and a potential alien invasion we'll get
to that very soon this series may be
dying so please tickle the like button
to bring it back and let's jump into all
the map changes in week 10 of chapter 2
season 6. also kodadamaru
please and thank you
the big news of the week can be found
just above the dam location on the
riverbank
feast your eyes on this a crashed
helicopter has impacted the ground
whoever was in this is seriously hurt
the chopper is covered in io symbols
they're a little pixelated but we can
still make it out
at first i thought this was agent
jones's chopper from the solo event
earlier in the season
but heck no i'm completely wrong he was
on the battle bus before that crashed
in terms of the story we know io are the
ones outside the loop
watching us from the shadows last season
we saw their crest for the first time as
jonesy fought to keep us all locked up
inside the loop
but this season he switched allegiances
and joined the rebels
does this chopper mean iowa coming for
jones and venturing into the loop
here's a random flashback for you the
last time we saw choppers like these
it was back in chapter one and the shady
officials we called the government back
then
eventually found the vault and we all
know what happened
the power ranger mech versus your mum
i'd love that to happen again
have you been keeping an eye on deadshot
this season after his og
sheriff office was blasted to
smithereens during the event
he set up a new home just outside leaky
lake over the next few updates he began
to build a jailhouse and settled in but
then he started arresting gnomes
maybe they were criminals i don't know
but one week later he arrested more
and then the week after that even more
and today
look at this genome's officially in
captivity
some sort of racism here the last time
the genomes were kept prisoner
we had the epic battle between them and
the misfits
i checked up on graham our lord and
savior to make sure he's okay
and he's still here still watching over
us he's got tired legs though he needs
somewhere to sit
well whilst here i noticed a new asset
an old cv radio is now set up
is this new i can't say i've checked
here very often and also why the heck is
harry potter's sorting hat here
weird this is probably a tinfoil hat to
represent those people who are really
into ufo sightings
and being anally probed can i say that
well as it turns out these are all
challenges foreshadowing the new season
we'll get into them very soon first more
map changes
remember all the locations building up
barriers to protect themselves from the
primal corruption at the spires well
that storyline seemed to end without any
real
reason but before it did it gave us
another clue this week
around the island are these posters the
most densely packed is at sweaty sands
and hotel 23.
from afar they appear to be adults and
children holding hands
but get your face closer to reveal the
truth this poster shows humans and
aliens
holding hands rumors of an alien-themed
sci-fi season
are picking up pace with images like
this so how do aliens usually speak to
human beings
crop circles right let's get over to
colossal crops
oh well that's a strange turn of events
i was kind of expecting a crop circle to
be here but instead
all the crops have now been farmed this
at least tells us we're on the right
tracks
but every single hayfield is now bailed
away
i guess we keep an eye on the cornfields
next
another thing that gets me most excited
when i see them in fortnite
tv screens but not just any tv screens
new ones fortnite assist showed me this
one over by the two high-fiving bros
hidden behind a bush waiting ominously
we know fortnite loves to use tv screens
as a way to count down to events
we've seen them multiple times like when
the ice king bored us all to death and
made everything snowy
and what about the og gremlin that was
found in the tv it was like an easter
egg for save the world back in the day
they may be called idiot boxes but they
are useful expect to see these things
come to life over the next week
okay we're gonna talk about the fortnite
crew packs in a moment but i wanted to
backtrack a fortnight to last update
which i was unable to cover
as you all know by now the steaming
island became the home of aurelia
and the golden scar it was also the home
of the lara croft anniversary easter egg
you know where she turned into gold and
this is a reference back to when she
touched the midas statue
all those years ago that update also saw
buildable and destructible sandcastles
for a challenge while in the replay
files
it was also possible to spot these and
they remain in the game
right now on many of the hills around
the island lay broken telescopes
we were unsure of their relevance back
then but now we have the concept of an
alien themed season
these telescopes become key to finding
flying sources in the night sky
and anyway telescopes have always been
everywhere in fortnite it's like their
calling card
what could they be looking at oh one
more thing before we move on it's
totally stupid and it's my favorite
thing this week
there's always been a chair sat on the
hill above the cabin and lake
it's a nod back to the old g island and
the original chair we used to find
well take a look at it today tiny chair
it's so cute a few people have noted the
chair has become smaller in recent
updates
sadly i don't have any footage of that
but right now i think we can all agree
it's a miniature chair now tiny chair
hashtag tinychair
i wonder if this is the official size of
a gnome graham
you may have a seat
okay on to the fortnite crew earlier in
the chapter the fortnite crew released a
skin
with a backstory v v however you say it
a foxclan operative attempting to find
drift well that story died out
and we were all left wanting well it's
happening again let's hope it's
more this time each week this month
those in the crew have received regular
loading screens
doesn't sound like much i know but
here's the thing they are actually
presented like a story just like they
did back in chapter one
a backstory of cuddle team leader and
her origins
the timeline begins with our cuddle team
leader rifting away
to another world a technological haven a
week later she had used all her newly
found nerdy tech skills to build an
advanced cuddle team suit
almost like a mech this was followed up
again with a loading screen
showing her progress and survival skills
in this new world
can we take a moment to look at the
speeders here if these are the vehicles
coming next season
count me in hovering vehicles are just
cool and finally today
take a look-see at this cuddle team
leader rifts back to our world
fully upgraded looking like a complete
badass
to confirm it is this season we see
agent jones in his primal attire
not looking too aware what the heck is
going on then the final shocker
look at the characters here birdie
poggers is always good
but what about this silhouette just here
it's got to be loki right
there's no mistaking it the god of
mischief is on his way to fortnite
put all these things together we have
another world technological advances
and loki season 7 is already feeling 10
times better than the current season
[Music]
here's a cool thing i completely by
accident stumbled across
up on top of mount yate in the replay
files sits
this crystal shining blue all
spectacular
so i decided to take penny over there to
see what happened
and nothing at all happened but wait
that's not the end of this story
when i shuffled back in the replay file
watch the magic
the crystal comes alive and shines pink
purple
red pink i have zero idea what this is
for is it a challenge i'm yet to
complete
or is this part of the story could this
be the key to next season
hit me with your theories please if you
want to see this yourself
you need to jump into a replay file okay
so this really leads on to a real
question i have and i need your advice
next season should i stick to the story
beats and map changes or would you like
me to start incorporating leaks into the
videos
i don't know where my place is covering
fortnite to be honest anymore and i
thought i'd ask you guys what you want
from me
i'm open to criticism and redirection so
please hit me with your thoughts
tell me what you want right oh i'll get
out your face i'll see you later in the
week with a full story recap of the
season
and also the new batman update when that
drops too on screen now are the code
adamaru legends
who keep me going thank you all so much
i'm adam you're awesome
i shall see you next time